this this event is sponsored by Public
Square if you guys want to help win the
culture war and support businesses that
support our values download the Public
Square app check out businesses in your
area I really do mean it both parties
are working for the same special
interests you know big Pharma isn't just
given checks to one side or the other
the military industrial complex is not
just writing checks to Republicans you
have the the major interests that
control this country than just utilize
the parties to be their valet and being
a little bit better of a valet or the
lead valet as opposed to the secondary
valet is just not a game I want to win
Donal Donald Trump in the white house he
he is not the the creator of everything
we see in the culture war in our
politics he is an avatar of the anger of
so many people and you know what when
Donald Trump won in 2016 it was just the
presidency meanwhile Congress was still
establishment the Supreme Court was
still establishment and even right now
even with Trump's nominees you still get
a bit of that establishment Thomas and
Leo are pretty good we're now seeing
Maga in Congress and when they say the
Republican part is not unified I'm like
good it means there's some people who
are actually representing me at least
even if it is only a small handful of
people you know when we were unified
when we passed the Patriot Act you know
when we were unified when we went to war
in Iraq you know when we were unified
when you know when when we were willing
to take you people's Liberties away
during coid you know when we were
unified when we were printing money for
extra coid spending Unity has brought
some of the worst results we need
dissent we need the opportunity for
people to make a counterargument and
then have the best ideas rise to the top
I I actually don't disagree with what
you're saying there because I don't know
if you guys have read musk's recent book
it's a phenomenal book to read Walter
Isaacson one of the things he said we
had a culture that if you work with them
he said he's not a fan of camaraderie
because camaraderie prevents people from
calling out each other's so it
kind of validates what you're saying I'm
with it that's not what I'm I know the
enemy is the establishment I I fully
understand
but I also think we have to kind of get
in to be able to impose the philosophies
and ideas that we have so going back to
the question I was asking you did you
actually think you were going to get him
to be the first to get fired did you
actually think that was going to happen
or were you like look I'm just trying to
scare the crap out of him because he
made a promise to me or you like no
we're getting rid of him I I'd made an
existential decision that I wasn't going
to own him anymore that there were there
were a group of us that was large enough
where if we weren't going to vote for
him one of two things was going to
happen the Democrats were going to own
him or he was not going to be the
speaker anymore and I was actually okay
with either one of those results because
either is Illuminating and either
creates opportunity so I had no
foresight as to how the Democrats were
going to act I kind of had a feeling
they were going to resent the fact that
he lied to them just like he'd lied to
us um but I you know I I went out pretty
publicly in a number of interviews and
just said we're going to file the motion
at vacate we got enough Republican votes
where he won't stay the Republican
speaker you guys either adopt him or
ditch him but either way and I'm not
deis I'm not so sure it matters Unity uh
when it comes to electoral politics
either you're going to have people in
their districts Comm communicating and
and and looking towards their single
member of Congress and there may be a
rhino as people would describe them in
in some District they're not going to
blame their member of Congress for the
actions of other members of Congress
they'll simply go to and say hey we want
the Republican wi to win and unify will
you try and unify yes I will they're not
going to vote Democrat because Matt
Gates is arguing with them no I don't
disagree that all I'm thinking about is
Optics thinking about the voter I'm
thinking about in every possible way
this is favoring conservatives to be
able to win 2024 in every possible way I
was wondering if you did this thinking
it was a way of scaring him or you did
this thinking he's going to get fired
and that was the intentions because the
reality of it is what kind of helped you
Matt is the fact that there was not a
red wave in in November of last year if
there was a Red Wave you guys wouldn't
have enough leverage to be able to get
rid of them well it depends on who would
have won you know if you could have had
if I had Caroline levit Joe Kent J.R
majusi you know some of these America
First candidates that that McCarthy
starved of resources uh and people who
should have been there in Congress you
know if we' had those folks you know
maybe even a larger majority would have
led to more people with u the desire to
push back against the traditional tra
trajectory didn't the GOP go against
Blake Masters as well I I know more
about the house politics and the Senate
politics it's it's it seems to be story
after story that the machine itself will
push out anybody who would end up
actually trying to fight for change or
what the American people care about yeah
you think politics is bad try the media
oh yeah I mean but but you think about
how what we're doing now I mean there
there was a great piece in semaphor that
came out today that talked about how
what was remarkable about our efforts
was that we were able to go around even
traditional conservative media and even
around Fox News and the way we were able
to do that was by utilizing podcasts by
using alternative media by even
utilizing opposition media I did more
consequential interviews on this subject
on CNN than I ever did on Fox News and
uh I think that there's there's a
fragmented environment in the media
landscape right now that we have to be
ready to seize on the the conservative
media landscape has actually never been
more there for the taking I think I
think the liberal media landscape as
well it's so
devoid really truth kind like I don't
know what it is if you can sense
someone's Soul when you look in their
eyes we need more of that I don't know
what it is exactly but like dogs can do
that yeah a lot of animals can right
they like we talk about unity and I
agree with you guys Unity can be very
dangerous like Hitler was all about
unifying that country for horrible that
means so you want disperate unity and I
think it's the idea of God I don't want
to be take it religious if we don't have
to but there is something we can unify
under which is consciousness and then
then we just argue about everything else
that's the point I it does feel
sometimes that you know like everybody
in this room I'm willing to bet could
have like a three-hour conversation with
you about their ideas their proposed
Solutions what they think works and
doesn't and then you look to these these
uh other audiences typically the
corporate press and the mainstream media
and these people will have no idea give
you an example how many how many
liberals and leftists have come on
timcast IRL and I say did you see the
video of Joe Biden talking about
withholding the billion dollars over the
barisma thing and they go no what are
you talking about and I'm like now how
do you not know that it's a huge subject
of the debate in politics they don't
know these things it's almost like
they're not they're non-player
characters we that's that's where the
NPC meme basically comes from and then
you have people here who are going to
argue with us in fact what I love about
Tim cast irell is our Super Chat
corrects our errors real time it's kind
of crazy that that it's such a robust
Community I need a Super Chat yeah I
wonder if AI can sort of aggregate me as
Super Chat kind of walk around Congress
and you guys can just correct all my
mistakes
my favorite example my favorite recent
example is not political at all it's
when Hassan perer called Phil leonti a
failed musician
guy who had just opened from Metallica
has a platinum record five gold records
and a massive band and it's and it's and
what I find hilarious about it is of
course Hassan could not say lead singer
of All That Remains he had to keep it as
vague as possible because they need to
keep their audiences misinformed or
underformed because if they actually
were telling people what was going on
their ideas would be very different but
it's it's to to go back to what Ian was
saying it basically feels like many of
these people are not conscious they're
just along for the ride and not paying
attention it's almost like they're blue
pilled like they're chasing the money no
like they're they're not awake it's
funny that they call themselves woke but
they're more asleep than anybody the
people who are awake are are are
debating well but isn't don't you just
have to relent relentlessly confront
those people with reality and then you
know you you have to you have to Spice
in enough uh energy to to get eyeballs I
mean we are all in the attention economy
right I want your attention for my
policy ideas and and political goals you
know advertisers want your attention to
buy their products news organizations
wants want your attention to be able to
sell to those advertisers and I mean I
remember you know what was it when you
dressed up like Osama Bin Laden and went
across the Rio Grand you know you were
able to use and a viral video to to make
an argument that that broke through that
typical monop dressed like a terrorist
and uh I got the costume from Party City
and I swam across the Rio Grand how did
that help you with TSA so this is like
we'll get to that in a minute and this
is like nine years ago and I I swam
across the river and I was looking
anywhere for border patrol and I found
one I and I ran towards him and he drove
in the opposite
direction and then like a few months
later I was targeted the border and in
Canada and and harassed but um I think
the solution is not political what Matt
does I don't I can't even copine on that
I think it's we need to every one of you
out there and I've said this a hundred
times you're the media you you are the
journalists and what what people need to
see is people people need to see like I
can't imagine the conversations Matt has
seen and witnessed in in the halls of DC
this week and if those are recorded like
people need to see it and my problem is
um as a investigative reporter I get you
know 100 legitimate legitimate people a
day contact me with all types of
problems please come to the welfare
office in this state expose this agency
but then when puss comes to shove they
don't they don't do it why because
they're afraid because they're afraid to
take that that action that they are
afraid to go do it for fear of
retaliation I have we talked about this
I have a family I have children I have
this I have that and I and I and I have
to say what what type of world are your
children going to grow up and if you do
nothing they'll live in the Pod and
they'll eat the bugs they'll live in the
Pod and eat the bugs that's right if
they're lucky if they're lucky that's
right and get Mario carditis you never
know it might we might end up you might
end up doing nothing and things get
great I don't think it's going to happen
that way so there's no reason to be
turned off or to use it as a fear not to
be like if you don't do anything you'll
be horrible things horrible things will
like you don't want to scare people but
why not you don't want to scare people
into action I would rather Inspire them
into action with an idea stick with a
with an Ang with a direction like uh we
could start pulling the carbon dioxide
out of the atmosphere and converting it
into graphine
[Music]
[Applause]
reindustrialize and then sell it all
over the Earth wow I by the way if that
doesn't inspire people I don't know what
will oh it's going to be very
inspirational K and stick I think um if
if there's I I love using the burning
building analogy you have to explain
fire bad right it's not like hey it's
sunny out side with flowers and there's
dogs and puppies that's your incentive
to get out of the fire no get out of the
fire because you're going to die right
so it just depends on the so do you
think it's just we're in a situation
where it's dire enough that it it it
warrants using fear to motivate it is so
dire is terrifyingly dire look look
should we go I mean I used to do this
list of all the up they're
doing but now in the past couple of
weeks I mean they my what they're doing
in New York to Donald Trump they are
trying to seize his properties through
this circuitous legal method where like
okay we're suing Trump for 250 million
we sum summarily determine Trump
overvalued his properties now we're
determining in a trial whether or not he
falsified records if they're already
saying a $500 million property which
actually is is only 50 then any record
created is falsified by their standard
they're then going to say Trump you're
found liable for $250 million and
they're going to seize a $500 million
property Market off as worth 50 and then
tell say Trump owes another 200 this is
what's literally happening right now
they've arrested Trump's law lawyers
that and and a lot of people didn't even
follow this the lawyers who argued on
Trump's behalf over 2020 which you are
you are absolutely in my opinion
required to do under this constitution a
Regis of grievances if you feel you are
wronged you get your lawyer you file the
paperwork that is the way you do it and
they sanctioned Trump's lawyers in
Colorado two of them $187,000 a
collective million for several other uh
lawyers now Jenna Alis and several other
lawyers are indicted the the dire is an
understatement if you look to history
Mike cernovich is talking about the
regime framing him for a crime and
killing him and a lot of people gets you
know they say okay you're freaking out
it's a little crazy I'm like dude would
you have believed January 6 would have
happened six months before no one
thought something like that was going to
happen whether whatever your view is a
riot people peaceful protest on one side
it's still a shocking moment in history
if you said Trump's lawyers would be
arrested nobody would believe it so when
we have them trying to seize Trump's
assets and destroy him with government
power I got to tell you man history
dictates I mean or I should say history
doesn't repeat it Rhymes and we are
looking down the barrel of very
terrifying if you read uh uh I I
think it's holy F I did not read sulit
in the gulag archipelago but there's
that famous quote I just posted I've
seen where he mentions a guy a military
officer was about was being beaten and
he pulls out a knife and stabs the asant
so he gets charged with murder for it
that's what it was like in the Soviet
Union and I'm like well that's really
funny that's literally happening here
today thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 P.M
and become a member over at timcast.net